well one of North Las Vegas's first
families has returned home after half a
century in a lab these bodies uncovered
in the 70s were from the Keel family
over the years people more commonly
refer to them as the Kyle family but
promises to return them did not happen
until recently Ryan Matthey explains his
decades-long homecoming
before there was North Las Vegas there
was the key family they were one of
Southern Nevada's first families and in
the late 1800s five of them were buried
right here but nearly 50 years ago
without the family's permission they
were dug up they had been initially
promised to be returned soon quickly
immediately kind of thing but that
didn't happen for years historian Joe
Thompson says the bodies remained at
unlv's anthropology lab for study after
an anthropology Professor there dug them
up in 1975. how would you like to have
your grandmother and grandfather just
dug up and Drug around the country and
and put on display then Colleen Herbst
and Patricia reinsback got involved
their great-great-grand Uncle Conrad
Keel settled this property and was
uncovered with the rest of his family
they were buried on this land that's
where they chose to be and wanted to be
and it's like okay they've
why weren't they returned after two
decades of navigating laws regulations
and City Council meetings the bodies
finally returned to its burial in 2019.
[Music]
Friday the family joined Thompson for a
reparation ceremony for their ancestors
who they say are back to resting
peacefully our goal was to get the
bodies returned to their land and feel
very very thankful that that finally
took place and the historian had several
other bodies that were dug up in the
same area currently remain at UNLV
reporting from Kyle Ranch rymathy 8 News
Now